I'm Mindy Kaling I'm going to be the
moderator for the global press
conference and yeah I'm just really
excited to introduce everyone for this
first panel the person is JJ Abrams
director producer co-writer of the movie
uh Daisy Ridley who plays ray right here
Jada in my massive white sofa come sit
this is Daisy Ridley I hated the route
Adam driver
young girl is Maz Kanata Carrie Fisher
what a dispute here should sit down take
the great where's Gary she's coming very
scary
she's hanging I'm the last one now when
I was I'm just gonna start um my name is
Mindy Kaling well and I know when you
think of me the first thing you think of
is a huge Star Wars fan um but I
actually am a Star Wars fan because um
Star Wars is um it's a movie a series of
movies a Carrie come on here please need
some convincing yeah sure right next to
you before and after oh um I was just
think the reason I love Star Wars is
that I think it defines genres I think
that parts of it are better than any
romantic comedy you could watch it's an
action movie it's a buddy movie there's
interspecies friendships in fact it's
everything except those boxing movies
that come out every holiday season it
really has everything and um I thought I
would just tell you guys a little bit
more about it um I'm here to run this
press conference for a movie that needs
no introduction but I love to talk so I
am going to say a little bit more on May
27th 1977 George Lucas's Star Wars
opened in US theaters no one could have
predicted the huge impact the
imaginative movie would have on people
not just on audiences of the time but
generations to come
the film went on to garner 10 Academy
Award nominations spawn the birth of the
visual effects industry and rewrite the
future of filmmaking in filmmakers the
force awakens begins a whole new chapter
in the story saga
good luck Jay de
while doing research on this I saw every
interview that these guys have done and
I talked to JJ and I did want to ask
them any questions that you could just
google the answers for for instance if
you asked AZ Ridley how she felt when
she was cast she's going to say very
excited so I thought I would ask some
questions that I have never heard
actually Adam driver you were like never
seen them not a fan which I thought was
pretty anxious never mind so JJ uh I
thought I would start by asking you the
question I think everyone wants to ask
you which is um aren't you rich why did
you want to do these movies don't you
have a hot wife it doesn't need you to
be in Abu Dhabi perform instead of time
if you want to borrow money from in with
I need $50,000 for an intervention I'll
talk about it later but enough get out
here's the thing this is a project that
I felt incredibly lucky to be asked to
be a part of and I think I speak for all
of us except for maybe Harrison when I
say this was not a job I'm kidding
Harrison you know I was was unbelievable
uh but the process of this movie the to
a person on the crew to a person on the
cast this was not a job and it was
nothing that I think any one of us took
on because it was a gig that was
available it was something that felt
like a true passion and something that
that every single person brought much
more than any of us could have expected
and so I I do honestly feel honored to
be part of this group excellent um who
was the most difficult actor to work
with I have a guess in my mind who it is
I'm curious with what you what your
answer is well it was it was definitely
whoever's not on this couch not it Oscar
Isaac definitely Oscar no no it was
everyone was was shockingly and eerily
wonderful to work with and and to get to
work with people like Carrie and
Harrison and Mark and people who I was a
fan of since I was 11 years old and also
actors like Lupita and Daisy and Adam
and John it it was so much fun to see
them work together and to see how that
alchemy came out and it was really a
spectacular and fun thing every day on
set um it's great answer uh Carrie I
have a question for you I'm a big fan of
your writing I love postcards from the
edge you coined one of my favorite lines
ever which is do you always speak and
bumper-sticker
and I've seen a lot of interviews with
you and wife speaking Africa every other
one one thing I can say about you is it
you do not speak and bumper-sticker
and I think it's because you get asked a
lot of stupid questions oh that's silly
and I was gonna ask you you have an
amazing sense of humor do you think that
Princess Leia has a good sense of humor
she would have to wearing those hair
pieces and well you should know that
this is all someone else's hair okay so
Betty Jo help um hmm Adam um kylo Ren
looks hilarious and normal again I have
not seen the movie but in all
seriousness he seems very focused and
obsessed and in my mind he's like Robert
De Niro's character and king of comedy
uh is any of this even approximating the
truth again I've not seen the movie if
so I'm a genius if not then what what is
he like although read Rupert Pupkin
ladies even broken and Lawrence you can
answer this question too it makes a lot
of videos for his mom makes a lot of
industries mom listen is uh he's uh he's
a great cook you know he's a Scorpio
I think he's very unpolished and
unfinished and I think what JJ and Larry
did keeping all the vocabulary that
everyone's very familiar with the Star
Wars and the darkside and keeping that
very much intact but also adding a kind
of recklessness or something that's kind
of unmeet about it that I think people
normally associate with the dark side
being organized and very you know in
control and calm and in command the dark
side is extremely organized extremely
organized in a very evil way is that
something that you've continued well
Larry you want to speak to this but one
of our thoughts was to try and do
something that felt a little bit
different in that regard yes and that's
why we were so excited about Adam
playing this part because there's never
been a character like Kyllo in the saga
and no he hasn't got it all together and
and Adam a exit so beautifully because
you what you're looking at you know you
expect it oh this is some evil genius
you know but what you're getting is all
the contradictions and the conflict that
people feel any one of us can feel at
any moment that's so amazing about it in
that and I think that's what's unique
about what Adam has done um Lupita you
play a former space pirate who now runs
a bar um I'm wondering a the Seema sort
of to me like a female Sam Malone from
the American TV show Cheers
Yoda is norm this may not you might not
know this I'm just gonna say could you
talk about your relationship with Yoda
and is it is it convivial hah he doesn't
tell her a little bit about the
structures actual I said okay he was my
first love no that's a movie I would
like to see yeah that's a good movie -
yeah ideas for Disney
um yeah what ha ha ha question let's
talk a little bit about your characters
relationship with Yoda which is
something I like to can she know I will
say this in an attempt to save my friend
Lupita okay from this slightly odd
awesomely geeky pinky question which is
that I do believe that Maz and and Yoda
at one point had crossed paths but that
is not something of course due to the
events of past poems happens in this one
okay okay yeah what do you say yeah
I recently were in a play on in your
city and I'm wondering what the
experience was acting with other actors
versus what I can only imagine in this
was at some times a very solitary
experience shooting this movie and yeah
fortunately for me JJ had me be a part
of principal photography so my very
first experience of motion capture was
on the actual sets with the actual
actors so I am eternally grateful to him
for giving me that because it was a
great way to get into this wonderful
crazy thing called motion capture I got
to be on those sets and see those things
and feel them and the art direction in
this there's so much detail even when
you're standing on that set that is it's
mesmerizing and I think audiences are
going to be there they're there they're
going to have a very immersive
experience much like we had filming it
and so it was good to have that and the
physicality is something that then
carries on into theater for sure and
that was the thing that attracted me to
the idea of playing motion capture the
the idea of working on a character that
wasn't limited by my friends my physical
circumstances and I could I could work
with my body in new ways and I've
continued that onto the stage without
going to say one thing that the Peeta
would not which is that she was
remarkably tireless and and willing to
experiment with different versions of
this character and it was kind of an
amazing thing to discover
over various iterations of Moz what she
sounded like how she moved it was really
I've never been through this before with
an actor where we got to discover again
and again and again kind of how to
better tell the story we were telling
and it was just I I always felt guilty
every time we started up another session
another we did some reshoots it works
and every single time Lupita was willing
and game and and deeply committed and
into finding maz kanata's voice and I
again I'm just eternally grateful Thank
You Jane it's confirmed something I came
into this thinking which is that Lupita
Nyong'o is a good actress I was I was
shocked to discover she spectacular it
never crossed my mind
Daisy I know we have questions from
everyone here but I was have a question
for you which is athletes have a walk-up
song which is when they're entering an
arena they have a song that they've
chosen to like pumps them up and
expresses who they are Ronda Rousey's is
Joan Jett song bad reputation and I was
wondering what your characters walk-up
song might be I actually have one Oh mr.
Jane and uh not to advertise Disney
anymore but it's Mulan I'll make a man
out of you I'll make a man out of you is
your water yeah I used to play it in the
trailer before I went on we get a little
bit oh my god mr. uh make the man out of
you its iconic guys so I think we should
open up questions I have more but I'll
pop it in appropriately please um okay I
okay
yeah you sir the glasses thank you for
letting me come to this my question is
for mr. JJ Abrams what was the most
important thing to bring to the force
awakens from the original trilogy to you
when Kathy Kennedy and and Larry and I
started talking about what this was at
the very beginning the
the fundamental question was what did we
want to feel then what do we want people
to feel when they came to this movie and
that was really the beginning of the
discussion and the answer was a the kind
of sense of discovery exhilaration
surprise the the comedy that that George
Lucas put into Star Wars kind of was the
for me the thing that made me love the
movie but when you look at all the
things that he got right it's impossible
and stunning and so for us at the very
beginning it was really about knowing
why we were telling the story and it was
to give people that sense of possibility
and magic that we all felt when we first
saw the original Star Wars but I would
just say that this is all to tell a new
story meaning it's not a nostalgia trip
we had to go backwards in order to go
forwards and if you look at four or five
and six those are stories that continue
this is seven so the history of seven
will be what we've seen before so the
fabric needed to be that that we are
familiar with in order to tell a
brand-new story thank you hi um so this
question is for Carrie and Daisy
um can you talk a little bit about
bringing out the girl power in the
original trilogy and also the force
awakens
JZ you guys you begin you begun this
whole thing I am the beginning of girl
power
yes deal with it no I did I got to be
the only girl on the all-boys set which
was really fun you know to put things in
their drinks and stuff like that we
drank through the whole trilogy in the
beginning this was a sober set so um
that's what JJ brought to this was
sobriety um girl power
she's more powerful in the girl path
yes I'm louder than you so she takes on
the physical power and then I screamed
with them until they pass out not scream
I make fun of them you know that was
what was really fun about doing anything
that girl power esque uh is bossing men
around I know a lot of you women out
there haven't done that yet and I
encourage you to do so tighter this
afternoon over there okay oh we did it
Daisy please yes exactly
okay and well obviously Princess Leia
and Kari is a source of inspiration for
girls for the past 30 years and and I'm
definitely not quite there yet but I
hope Rey will be something of a girl
power figure and I think with writing
like JJ and Larry's and with a story of
which she is was woven into richly and
holds an important role and I guess
there's no other way except to say that
she will have some impact in a girl
power II way I'm so not eloquent sorry
she's she's brave and she's and she's
vulnerable and she's so nuanced that's
what's so exciting playing the role like
this
she doesn't have to be one thing to to
embody a woman in a film and for me
she's not important because she's a
woman she's just important it just so
happens that she's a woman like she
transcends gender she's going to speak
to men and women and but obviously we
were started with layer and layers still
they're kicking ass
we got Mars kicking ass too so it's
wonderful to be part of obviously with
Kathy at the helm as well a wonderful
crew and cast of wonderful women hey
guys wanna say a Kari you were my first
role model when I saw it at seven over
here oh yeah I am your first role model
that's right that's what I most Jukka um
anyway for for JJ you're usually very
secretive around your your films
was it heart-wrenching for you to let go
of some of the footage no no I the
contrary actually it was something that
while we were working on on the movie I
realized how engage with the fans and
forthcoming Lucasfilm had always been
and my nature which is to keep things
quiet was something that I was certain
we are going to have fights about and my
wanting to keep the audience surprised
when they went to see the movie but
Disney to my shock was arguing to not
ruin not reveal not show every story
beat and we've all seen trailers for
films that literally show you the movie
in CliffsNotes form and then you go to
see the film and you're like yeah that
was literally the movie I saw it in a 2
and 10 sec 2 minute 10-second piece so I
was very grateful that that Disney
actually took the lead on trying to keep
things quieter and you know obviously I
ask all of you who we are incredibly
grateful for your being here that when
you do see the movie and hopefully talk
about it to your fans and readers and
stuff that that we maintain some
level of surprise for people get to see
the movie and and don't have it ruined
for them just because it's finally been
released which I cannot wait for by the
way it's very such a special film
because my husband for mid being
forbidden me to see the film by myself
cuz he said it's an experience that we
have to experience together because
we're both Star Wars fans
yeah but I'm listening to Carrie you
should just boss them around and tell
him you'll do any work I'll try that but
that work that's wanted to know from the
cast members do you have family members
or friends or probably in Europe I've
heard from other people similar stories
that they're forbidden to see the movie
without them so I think it's really
funny that people are putting these
pressures on people or this particular
movie the movie with uh our parents is
that your question yeah I find that it's
really a family except you know I've had
people over the years coming I'm showing
this to my child that you know I didn't
want to wait till they were six so I
went with five and you watch your
children watch the movie and you learn
something about your children and we'll
we like the same characters and
Halloween becomes kind of more of a
Thanksgiving experience without the
turkey but it's I just you see all these
pictures of entire families dressed as
the characters and it's I find that soap
moving sorry but I do it's just an
amazingly emotional movie question over
here
hey there I'm rich Pulaski from sky
walking through Neverland I'd like to
know from each of you what was the
scariest moment on your very first day
of production or what was the scariest
scene to write from mr. Kasdan um you
know I don't associate the process with
fear JJ and I am jumped into the thing
under a lot of time pressure and we had
fun and and in fact the first day that
we started real work on it we said you
know we must have fun with this every
day it's really
AB privilege and you have to be very
lucky to get to write the next Star Wars
and so we didn't really have fear I
think we had trepidation about
fulfilling people's expectations that
they'd be satisfied but what we came out
with but we didn't want them to know
we're gonna come up with and we wanted
that this moment that's coming up next
week would be a fresh moment for the you
know as many people in the world who
were interested in it so that the only
pressure is can you do something that's
worth that much anticipation bad memory
yacht remembering my lines that was
scary no and I also I'm the custodian of
Princess Leia so I never got out of
character and I wondered if that would
be noticed no uh but I was very nervous
just it's been you know 40 years for
other people in the know it's been a
long time and uh and I don't like
looking at myself at this age in a large
way so that was scary and remained so
this question are we going through
Lupita plenty for me was I playing a
motion-capture character this was
something completely new to me and
walking into a room I had to do this
thing where they had to take my picture
from all directions at one time and I
had to stand in the middle and there was
360 cameras all around me and that
freaked me out uh I don't know I got I
guess I'm kind of terrified before most
jobs so the prospect of this the Star
Wars and all the kind of iconography
associated with it like I tried to not
think about as much as possible so maybe
when it when it first started and then
kind of suppressing that as much as
possible and trying to break it up into
moment so then that way but I remember
like a
one one thing in particular that that's
in particularly terrifying my whole
first day was pretty terrifying I
couldn't find a moment that was any less
or more than the other I think for me
it's and being cast in a role as
everyone knows I've not really done much
before and so other people saw something
in me that perhaps I didn't see myself
and I'm still not quite sure if it's
there and so so I have the fear of not
fulfilling that potential was terrifying
uh just listening to what the people
were saying it just remind me people
have said to me I don't understand you
you cast someone so beautiful as Lupita
and then you had to be a motion-capture
character and I think would it be okay
she were ugly but you know anyway uh I
cannot wait for you to see the work that
everyone on this couch has has done in
the movie uh the scariest day for me was
when Harrison Ford was injured Oh which
is a just absolutely idiot the every day
felt like there were challenges because
I knew how important this was to so many
people and I that was never a presence
that went away and so every every
decision I knew had this importance and
yet we had a day to make we had a story
to tell and it was always about trying
to do the best work possible thank you
Andy Howells science for cinema and aina
Cool News this question is for JJ Abrams
since the original trilogy we've sent
probes to lots of the planets in our
solar system and we've discovered
hundreds of new extrasolar planets did
any thing we've learned from science
make its way into the design of planets
in this movie no
what about man Matt anything from you
know English you take that question you
go okay yeah no hi aasif comic acne it's
JJ um since you guys you two were really
the brainchild behind the story how much
did you guys look at the extended
universe and the extremely large canon
of books that have been written around
the Star Wars universe when you decided
to make this or was it more looking at
Return of the Jedi and just figuring out
how you guys feel it should have gone
hey what again um I think it had more to
do with Jedi and the continuation of you
know 4 5 & 6 this is 7 I think you know
we were aware were respectful of the
Canon but we really wanted to tell a
story that interested us and delighted
us and we weren't didn't really want any
rules and parameters particularly we
said well we can do anything we want
with this story what would be the most
fun thing to do on this page and the
next page and the page after that and
that was sort of the guiding principle I
think more than the Canon or anything
that had come before all the way over
here in the front well for the cast many
of us has been thinking about what
happened after Return of the Jedi for
the past 32 years did all of you have
those questions and when you got to
finally answer them did it live up to or
surprise your expectations I didn't
understand the question
and I I wasn't a huge fan of the whole
thing I'd seen them and I had a kind of
interest but I missed the souls go but
it was so and I didn't wander that so
much but even so it was very exciting
finding out what did come after Jedi I
would say that the that it's still
called Star Wars for me was really 18
that sounds lucre but it's the in a way
it's thirty years later but the exact
same things are going on in a way which
I thought was so telling of was so true
to life that even though it would I feel
like very we have such short memories of
huge you know events and mass genocide
then then we kind of forget about it it
seems and there's still the same people
are in charge and the same group of
people you know younger older everyone
comes on and feel that their problems
are unique and then it's all a cyclical
thing and it seems like finding these
people and a lot of things have changed
like the setting but but really the
circumstances are the same I felt was
very true and that for me was what I
took but less plot points and like oh I
always knew that you know Leia will be
doing this Orsola would be doing this
more like nothing really changes that
answered your question hi guys this is
for JJ and Lawrence um the names of the
characters have always been really
unique in Star Wars what's the process
that you guys used to come up with new
ones and did you use any that were left
over from mr. George Lucas no there were
any left over um I think the criteria
was did we did we like it that was it
really tough criteria you didn't sound
good to say it did it feel good to type
it yeah and don't you think yeah and a
lot of names came and went and some
names stuck and I remember when we put
down bb-8
it was a name that it was the first and
only name that droid ever had but we we
called him bb-8 and we still do Rey and
Finn and Poe went through many
iterations kylo ren was kylo ren fairly
early on and there was a sort of back
story and Maz Kanata I think was always
Maz Kanata so it's and we change lei his
name now we didn't really spell check hi
this message this question is for JJ are
there he walks in the movie that's all I
want to know why knows honor he walks um
living living listen if a man can't joke
with friends no there are no he walks in
in this film but you're aware of that's
right there were rumors of sunstruck
onset oh uh but there are a lot of them
in Return of the Jedi
I think question I have I have some more
questions um Lawrence this is a question
for you yeah um as a writer I find I get
a lot of inspiration from movies that
have nothing to do with what I'm writing
about I always look to the movie The
Fugitive because I just loved the script
and I was wondering and the answer just
could be no is there any movie that you
look to or thought about when you were
writing this one oh yeah surprised you
okay the all the movies of Akira
Kurosawa have influenced me throughout
my career that's because he was sort of
the Shakespeare of cinema he did
comedies he did action films he did
Shakespearean drama and all of life is
contained in each one of his film Seven
Samurai maybe the greatest film ever
made is you know it's a personal drama
it's an action picture so when did you
and I were working we kept referring to
that and then we would talk about the
great
Arkan movies that we loved and things
that had influenced the first Star Wars
which was Howard Hawks and John Ford and
you know all the Flash Gordon and
because when George made a new hope he
was influenced very much by Kurosawa and
by Flash Gordon and by The Wizard of Oz
and I think that all those movies are
you can feel them in a new hope and
everything that's in a new hope has come
down through them through the movies to
this day and JJ you drew inspiration
from the movie clueless when you were
talking about that to me was the
fundamental relationship between those
girls yes you know uh I don't like to
talk about it am I wrong you know okay
you're absolutely right it was clueless
oh let's take it let's test another joke
another present hi this questions for
Adam Star Wars has a legacy of really
great antagonist can you talk about
carrying that forward with kylo Ren uh
well I think a lot of it's not beyond my
control I would say again I feel like I
knew we're so aware of the movies and
like my friends kids now that they don't
know anything about they haven't seen
the movies but somehow so aware of
everything that happens and I think
that's how I was introduced to them
through like the merchandising and the
toys and you know stormtrooper helmets
and things like that and so I feel like
we try to sync about that as much as
possible and I remember early on we not
nothing of him being bad or evil or a
villain and try to make something that
was a more three-dimensional because
that to me I got when we were talking
originally seemed more dangerous and
more unpredictable someone who feels
morally justified in doing whatever they
need to to publicly kind of state that
what they're doing is right
seemed kind of something more active to
play than just being evil for the sake
of it that's
it's not really fun to play Hey I guess
Adam I was gonna ask you
you've worked two of my friends one of
them is Lena Dunham and one of them is
JJ Abrams are they in any way similar
yeah actually in an amazing ability to
compartmentalize and and I mean they do
this both in very different ways Vizio
Pass
yes sir sir they're both crazy nuts I
think that I would imagine the the
weight of something like Star Wars that
if it was me I would go nuts you know
having to be the kind of spearhead above
it or everyone's looking to you and
asking you questions and JJ was
consistently calm and couldn't have been
more collaborative and I feel the same
with with with Lena
I mean much is made about how young she
is but just because you can't help but
compare that or imagine what you were
doing at 22 or 23 she's she's like 28 or
29 Amy likes a guy yeah no not like a
wonderful engine I like Daisy it's okay
yeah thank you for answering that okay
hi guys I love to stay to the end of the
credits of every movie so I'm just
wondering is there an easter egg or an
extra scene at the end of this that we
should look forward to no there's not
what there will be now that way all the
scenes are actually in the movie ecstasy
this is scene I have a question about
costumes okay my first questions for JJ
Abrams which was the most difficult
costume to put together and then for
each of the characters I'd like to know
how long it took you to get into costume
so the the costume that was the most
challenging I think for us to arrive at
and Michael Kaplan the costume designer
I cannot wait for you to see what he's
done in this movie there are so many
cool and many you have not seen at all
costumes that are extraordinary the most
difficult one
was kylo Ren and we went through I don't
know how many hundreds and probably
thousands of iterations and different
versions and one of the great things
about that was over the course of that
the costume for Captain phasma was
designed that was actually pitched as a
kylo Ren costume originally and for
story reasons it didn't make sense and
didn't work but we suddenly realized oh
my god this is one of the greatest
looking costumes I've ever seen and and
he then she became one of my favorite
characters in the movie but the design
of kylo Ren was the most difficult one
and when we finally saw the mask and at
the beginning of that design it was
really instantly clear that was the
winner and I'm very grateful to Michael
and his whole amazing team it was their
question about how long it took to get
into the costume 20 minutes it does that
seem normal sure that's amazing okay
obviously yeah well cause putting the
doms things on and everything takes a
while in the wraps and everything had it
a wonderful one called Calais helping me
get the first time took like an hour and
a half then we got it down to like 20
minutes I think me it took about well my
costume I didn't have a costume because
I was a motion-capture character but to
get it up took about in the beginning it
took like two and a half hours maybe
three and then by the end we had it down
to about an hour an hour 15 Lupita had
dots on her teeth yeah like everywhere
she had dots all over the place and it
was I actually not until today have I
met her without doctors I'm still
finding them in things Thank You Larry
I was ready like that show up ready to
go
ah how long it take to get into costume
about 10 minutes for the 20 I'm older
and I'd do it faster no really 20
minutes I have a kind of classy gas
station attendant look there's not funny
so that doesn't good long develop my
favorite to give a classy gas station
well look at it I would say I was an
airplane repair McKesson with a nice
vest over that and different hair than
most airplane mechanics would normally
have the end there's been so much
amazing publicity for this film lots of
hype and product tie-ins and SNL
sketches and all kinds of stuff and this
weekend carries amazing interview and
Good Morning America went viral and
that's been my favorite piece so far
someone to ask me to expect to see Gary
has some kind of long tongued alien in
the film I wish I begged JJ and then
Gary was willing to sleep with JJ and I
mean AB Jill yeah that was the
enticement that's why I didn't go
forward on that note I think we have to
bring up the second the second group of
performers and actors guys thank you so
much oh good
I mean down
you